and they'll be seeing mike miner
for the fourth time already this year
how about it that's good for us him
anderson he's up over 300 again
anderson bounces it out to second
and whit will throw him out one away
fawn hits it deep to right field
the wind is blowing in from right so
that knocked that down some and dyson is
there for the second out 0-2 on jose
abreu last year's mvp
great pitch
a three-pitch strikeout against jose
abreu and a one two three top of the
first oh fights minor
dallas kykel on the hill
on for his 19th start he's looking for
his eighth win his era at 422.
been a pretty productive year for him
you can see not a lot of strikeouts not
a lot of walks but left-handers have
heard him swit merrifield in 2018 played
115 158 games and this is since 2018 he
is number one in major league baseball
in multi-hit games and total hits it's
really been amazing
reached out there and poked it to right
angle is there
for route number one they have to know
positioning in case they got the game in
front of them they're the only guy with
the game entirely in front of them and
they have to position
if they see people out of position so
they have to know game plan and
defensive alignments
change up struck him out dallas kikel
knows where to get that strikeout march
the 24th he jumped for that baseball
and the torn peck came on the reach
across
the line in left field but now four
months after eloy jimenez is back in the
lineup
broken back ground ball to shortstop and
hanser alberto throws him out
one down jimenez oh for one
change up mike miner has two perfect
innings
23 pitches 17 strikes
and solaire leads off a long drive deep
center back goes billy hamilton to the
wall and gone slowly that should be
worth two
as he clears all three walls to straight
away center field
my oh my was that a shot
you know you want to see this guy up
he's a sinker baller look him up but man
early in the count 449 dead center field
and he looked him up i'll say oh great
timing everything's just right
vaughn has been able to show the white
sox what he can do at the big league
level this year he's gotten a lot more
playing time and in the field with the
injuries to luis robert and eloy jimenez
and adam engel and
he's been hot in the last three weeks
there's a called third strike and a gift
from kerwin danley and miner has three
strikeouts nice job now
and you're gonna have to wait a while
because dozier's gonna throw out jimenez
inning over
so miners throwing strikes he's keep
being his defense on its toes and dozier
responds with a good fielding play and a
long throw so they're really beginning
to get into his game he hit one beyond
hamilton's range first time up he
cleared the padded wall the concrete
wall and the wooden wall
and that one's hit well to left field
and solaire goes deep again
and what has gotten into jorge solaire
the last week he now has six home runs
in his last six ball games flexing his
bustle some solar power
angle to left that is fair down the line
it goes there's the first hit and rings
around in the corner and adam hoofs it
to second base so adam engel has the
first socks hit a one-out double to left
billy hamilton
hit a soft liner to alberto at shortstop
in the third inning
hamilton strikes out on an elevated
fastball
and miner is struck out four yep that
fastball deserves a blue kc pitch tracks
up in the zone looks good to a lot of
guys but just hard to square up nice
pitch
adam engel is at second base with two
down
and mendic is down with a fastball miner
strikes out his fifth and he has five
scoreless innings
[Applause]
now dyson hits it well to right field
engel won't make a play and it's going
to bounce over the wall for a double
yeah jerrod good at bat he was all over
kykel you could tell he says all right
i'm gonna dumb it
yank this one he pulls it slider and
engel with great speed had no chance
over that so there's a runner in scoring
position for witt with two out
and a line drive to right he will add
another one
so dyson's double turns into a run and
now whit is going to round second and
head for third as engel bobbled it on
the line
and the royals lead three nothing in the
fifth andrew bond you take a look
weighted runs created plus against
lefties minimum 90 trips to the plate
andrew vaughn is the sixth most valuable
guy against lefties in major league
baseball but here he is one of the most
effective against lefties in baseball
right side base hit andrew vaughn again
against the southpaw tim is on his way
home as well it's a two-run single for
andrew vaughn and it's three to two
here in the sixth a two-strike huge hit
ben and tendy he has flied out to left
field and grounded out to second base
taking the left
and he will
it will carry
and it is gone
ding ding
so the royals answer right after the sox
got two
and the royals lead 4-2 how about going
to the opposite field that's right with
power
look at that that's three or four homers
this year we've seen hit him over that
over that left field wall he has five
saves
this year two
have been two inning saves so he's been
here before
and he just zipped right through the
white sox in the eighth and now jimenez
pops it up
and carlos santana and foul ground puts
it away
two and one
adam right side that's through it's a
base hit
you'll want around third he scores the
third run and now adam engel
has brought the sox within one run with
one out in the ninth
barlow's eighth inning was much easier
than this against the top three hitters
three up three down on eight pitches and
now goodwin gets jammed and with the
runner going
the royals are going to get a double
play to end the game
i don't know what you are so nervous
about hud yeah we had them all the way